all right let's turn first to uh
uh ah here okay great you know I bet you
that Perez is on her way over you think
she is okay hang on one
second ah there we go I knew you were
coming I was like I bet she's what about
mano page are they coming there's Manos
ah there's Manos there's Divine there we
go all
right Ming was here where did he go who
that Ming was here where did he yeah so
no he's here stuff he's getting
amendments okay and so we uh who we got
H there's all right there's Judy okay
and and thank you everybody on the
committee for your support of the Taiwan
resolution we appreciate that sure not
as much as they
do
okay all right so we're waiting we're
waiting for
rep AG he's right there okay good all
right all right so I'm just going to I
I'm not going to call vot
trip I know
trip yeah call
right said he was coming yeah I'm
surprised he's not here I thought he
would
be Ming will be right
here I cut
all just go start with
one yeah so um so uh I'm first going to
turn to House Bill
1069 and I'm going to recognize myself
uh for a motion and I'm going to first
deal with the amendment it's Amendment
um
046 and let me just take a minute to I
second sorry thank you thank you let me
just take a minute to um ah here's
repres to to um explain what this
amendment does it incorporates into
1069 um what was in 1069 with an
exception that I'll talk about in a
minute um and what was in the original
1696 and the changes that it makes to
those two bills are that first it
changes the language
that appears I believe in two sections
of the current right to no law talking
about every citizen it changes that to
any person so that uh citizen there's no
longer any reference to Citizen it's
only any person um the second change
that it makes and it appears on page one
of the amendment is it it allows
for um it allows for the requester
to request
um uh the records in either electronic
or paper form and requires the
municipality or the governmental body to
to honor that request unless there's
some really good reason not to do so
like there's real a real concern about
security um uh it would be unduly
burdensome or the requestor has asked
for for the records to be provided in
electronic form in some format that the
that the governmental body doesn't keep
they don't have to then honor that um It
also says that um no charge can be made
for the electronic delivery remember
bear in mind we're talking about
delivery not the searching for the
records or that kind of thing but no
charge can be made for electronic
delivery uh but a charge can be made if
you for postage if you if you send it
out by by uh mail um so that's the major
change the other change that I think
it's important to to uh to point out is
and this representative I thank
representative tur for really raising
this issue because I I would have
glossed over it in the original 1069 the
change that it proposed was to say that
preliminary drafts circulated to a uh
Quorum or a majority of the public
body have to be provided the problem
with that is if that if those records
already
exist they're covered by the right to no
law and they have to be provided in
other words if you if a if a if a
governmental body receives a draft
report and and they keep that
report then they have and there's and
there's then a request made for for uh
Records they they they have to provide
that just like they provide the final
the final report that's a that's a
document that exists in the records of
the
of the public body but if we were to
pass this this would say that you have
to keep the draft report even though
you've made a final report so the the
the you know that's like with anything
else if you if if a if a member comes to
the uh to a meeting of a the board of
Selectmen and makes some notes um and
you know his or her his personal notes
whatever they don't have to keep that
they don't there's no
requirement of keeping records that are
sort of in draft form so this is so
that's what representative tur raised as
a as an issue and I think he's I think
he was right on that so this this
removes that um so anyway that's what
this does um questions on the on the uh
on the amendment all right I don't see
any I don't yes representative uh G
all right so this is amendment
0237 no no no no
no4
right this
is 1069 right all right um any any other
questions all right so I think for on
the amendment we can do it by a hand
vote so I guess I would uh say all those
in favor uh please raise your
hand any
opposed seeing none all right so now
we're ready then for a motion on the
bill as amended um uh so it's otpa and I
will uh move the otpa on
1069 I'll second
that
second seconded by representative Perez
I
believe all right so um any further
discussion on the bill as amended all
right then I would ask the uh clerk to
please call the
role Vice chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander yes rep
Andrews re Stapleton yes rep trip yes
rep gson I'm not voting because I cannot
find the amendment to read
it have vot
yes rep Kap votes yes rep Perez yes rep
Smith yes rep organ yes rep dorenzo
yes rep Kenny yes rep Paige yes rep
Divine yes rep lonza yes rep Manos yes
rep chur yes rep Ming yes chairman Lynn
yes motion passes 19 to
zero all right and I will uh I'll write
the report on
that
190 okay all
right
pardon oh yes anybody have any problem
with this being on consent it's
not uh no this is not an early bill this
is not that's
right and then
um all right so now we turn to uh house
bill
1696 um which is the one that
contains um the amendment proposed by
representative Alexander and
representative yella uh and do I have a
motion on
that I recognize representative
Alexander thank you Mr chair I move um
HB 1696 ought to pass with Amendment an
amendment the amendment number 0237 each
all right is there a
second I second seconded by
representative uh
kutab uh all right uh representative
Alexander do you wish to speak to your
motion uh no I I think we've talked
about it at length I think it's um a
good bill to have in this committee as
opposed to another committee I think we
understand it better and that's
hopefully why the committee will support
this bill as amended thank you all right
anyone else wish to be heard on on uh uh
house on the amendment uh 0237 to House
Bill
1697 seeing none I guess we're ready I I
can do this by hand all those in favor
of adopting amendment 0237 to house bill
1696 please raise your
hand anyone
opposed represent you you you ra your
hand okay all right thank you
all right um and then I guess uh anyone
wish to speak so the amendment passes 19
to0 anyone wish to speak to the m to the
bill
otpa um
motion seeing none I would ask the clerk
to please call the
role Vice chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander yes rep Andrews rep Stapleton
yes rep trip yes rep gon yes rep kab
votes yes rep Perez yes rep Smith yes
rep Horgan yes yes rep D Lorenzo yes rep
Kenny yes rep paage yes rep
Divine yes rep lonza yes rep Manos yes
rep tur yes rep Ming yes chairman Lynn
yes motion passes 19 to zero all
right let me turn next to oh
representative Alexander can you write
the
report yes Mr chair thank you no
objection to consent oh uh uh no this
cannot go on consent because this is a
this is a money Bill so it'll have to go
on the have to go on the main
uh on the main calendar all right
um
next going to turn to House Bill
15 8 uh 89 that's the veter V Court bill
um and
um I'm I guess I'm going to recognize
myself first for
Amendment
and people don't have that Amendment she
handed that out at the
end3 it's uh it it's Amendment 03
34h
to House Bill
1589 okay
so I think you know what I think I sent
this yeah email via email right I'm
pretty sure I did yeah
um okay with it if you just tell her
what it says is this not the one that
you distributed at the end of the day
yesterday
that no
uh I don't know that I distributed at
the end of the day but so I mean I look
if anybody I I I know we're kind of in a
hurry but I if
people if people don't have this and you
and you want to have it I mean we you
know I I
don't we'll we'll get it and uh and get
a distribut before
we sure so you may remember that we had
um representatives from the judicial
branch that testified about this and
they suggested a number of
amendments main mainly it's to give more
flexibility if you will to the judicial
branch for um uh for example I I just
give you one big example the the
original Bill said there will be a
veterans court in every in every at
least one veterans court in every
District in a district court and a
superior court in every County the
judicial branch added language that says
um and I'm I'm just giving just you a
quote here um in the Court's discretion
in counties or districts where
participation may be low or whether
other administrative conditions may
exist considerations may exist a
veterans court may be a track of an
existing mental health court may be
combined AC course across different
counties or districts May utilize a
virtual docket or may employ such other
flexible measures as the court May
determine appropriate in order to
effectuate the the objectives of this
statute um so it's designed basically to
give more
flexibility um it um the other thing was
that there were there were a couple of
uh places where um the uh uh oh I know I
know another change was made you
remember the discussion about about um
who was a veteran so um one of the
witnesses who testified right from from
the uh from the uh State adant office
wanted us to use RSA 2150 the definition
of veteran in there so I looked at that
the problem with 2150 is that statute is
basically designed to deal with veteran
benefits so it I'm not saying it
exclusively deals with that but it
doesn't it didn't seem to fit and so
just to give you an
example it would have it would limit it
limits the definition of veterans if I
recall to honorably discharged or
discharged with o discharged under other
than honorable conditions but not
dishonorable discharge and my concern is
that remember what we're talking about
here we're just we're trying to provide
sort of special help to somebody who has
who who has a condition arising out of
their service so it seems to me and
again it's obviously whether somebody
qualifies or not is up to the court but
it seems to me we don't want to flatly
Prelude somebody that was uh
dishonorably discharged for example
suppose somebody was in a com you know
was in a combat theater they became drug
addicted they got dishonorably
discharged because they committed some
crime while they were in the service and
they still consider they still continue
to have some problems I don't think we
want to say that those people are you
know just as a blanket matter could not
be considered for the veterans court
maybe maybe the judge will say no for
whatever reason but they should at least
should be open to them so that's what uh
that's um why why that change was made
the I'm sorry yeah especially
considering the fact that the drug court
would be open to anybody regardless of
their service history right exactly
exactly that's the benefit extend here
the other language that I uh put in here
that the um judicial branch proposed to
change and I believe this is right and
I'm going to call on my my I spent one
term in finance but my colleague uh the
ranking member spent more than that um
the language was changed because of by
the judicial branch because the way it
was originally worded it would have
required um it it it could have been
read to say that um there was a
requirement to to provide to apply for
federal grants that could be used to
offset state grants and my recollection
for my short time in finance is you
can't do that the feds will not give you
the money if you say you're going to use
it to displace what the state would have
otherwise spent bent you can supplement
with Federal money but not replace and
so that language was put in there the
fancy word is suppliant supplant that's
it so so that's so this is this change
was made uh for that reason um I you
know there's probably a couple of other
little things but what I would say is
this I looked line by line at the
amendment um that that was provided by
uh
OS um to this and and it and to make
sure that it Incorporated all the
changes that I had requested based upon
what the what the uh uh uh the judicial
branch had had uh requested and they are
in here the changes the changes are in
here um there there you know I might
have I might have made some
non-substantive tinkering with the
language a little bit but there was no
substantive change from what the
judicial branch had requested questions
uh yes representative CH then
representative gree yeah just one other
comment another significant change that
I think was made was narrowing the scope
of military contractors which was wide
open before and is now says I believe
that they have to serve in a in a in a
combat theater or something along those
lines right no that's true because one
of the things that you may remember from
the the sponsor representative maet he
wanted to make sure that contractors
could be covered um but I think I think
what we didn't want to have happen is
you know somebody that somebody that's
uh
uh uh works for Lockheed Martin or
something and all they've and they've
just worked in the Pentagon as a as a
civilian never you know set foot
anywhere in a combat area I don't think
we want to cover I don't think we want
to consider them as somebody that's
covered so this limits it to combat
theater representative
grion an additional uh issue that was
brought up about qualification it would
be a current or former me military
member of a foreign Allied country um I
know I would not support that um the
changing the language of the contractor
uh is is is fine but this the in reading
the definitions of a veteran you are
actually eliminating anybody who's been
discharged from service because it says
a member of the active or Reserve
components of the United States Army
United States Navy etc etc or a member
of the national uh New Hampshire
National Guard those are active no no
this this have you got the right this
says a a a current or former a current
or former
member no that's that's in the amendment
that's in the amendment right okay
that's yeah that's why that's that that
that was I I'm I'm sorry I didn't
specifically cover that was in the I
made that change because of that very
issue the original Bill did not would
not have covered that so that's why I
put that language in a current or former
member and it that's the same with
current or former member of the new H
Hampshire National Guard a current or
former contractor of the United States
Department of Defense who served in a
theater of armed
conflict um so that I think that
covers
um other other
questions yes I have an email from umen
K yeah that the executive
session6 that well I I had her put that
in okay in case we couldn't get this
done today that was going to be the
alternative as we'd meet on Tuesday we
will can't if we get through the the
agenda today we will cancel that there
will be no meeting on Tuesday okay all
right so anybody else uh representative
Andrews somebody has a dishonorable
discharge are they included in this they
would they yes they could be covered by
this that's they don't that's not to say
it's not automatic it's up to the judge
but they could be
covered all
right
y
to oh okay um I don't see it on my email
okay no no no no I'm I yeah yeah no that
you shouldn't I I agre you should not be
voting on something you don't have
something exactly I I agree with
that yeah yeah of course we come back to
this that's fine
sure yeah there you go
great no problem any to please yeah
she's going to make copies I think for
every make copies for everybody
please all right yeah so I'm going to
recess uh uh discussion of HB
1589 uh and uh move on to uh House Bill
1651 relative to combining the board of
tax and land appeals and the housing
appeals board um I recognize
representative Smith thank you I would
like to is there a second second
seconded by representative trip uh all
right uh representative Smith do you
wish to speak to
uh well the direct answer to your
question is no I
don't um however what I will say is that
I think that the
um this gave us a very interesting
opportunity to hear more about two uh
disperate And I stress that disperate um
entities that we come in contact with
here in the uh judicial branch and um uh
I think on the basis of the testimony
both written and oral that was presented
and our evaluation of the bill um I
think it's safe to conclude that um
there there would be significant uh uh
costs not necessarily dollar costs but
programmatic costs and no real benefits
to combining the two all right anyone
else wish to be heard on representa trip
I would I would have to agree I think
the the uh the hab is uh uh still
maturing and that uh giving them any
more duties would be a
uh a detriment to
that in stage you know and I I think
that uh if if they were given new duties
without the uh necessary experience and
whatever they they might air so I would
not uh recommend the hab taking on any
new
duties uh other comments so I would just
say very briefly that I agree with uh
with what the two comments that have
been made by uh representative Smith and
representative trip I think that um
the at some point in you know in the
future maybe it would make sense to do
this but I think we need to see how the
hab is working out particularly when we
now have the new uh uh land use stocket
in the superior court I think it makes
much more sense not to do anything now
and to itl this bill anyone else have
anything to say about uh
1651 all right uh I guess we're ready
for uh roll call vote then
Vice chairman Wallace yes rep Alexander
yes rep Andrews yes rep
Stapleton yes rep trip yes rep gon
yes rep kab votes yes rep Perez yes rep
Smith yes rep Horgan yes rep D Lorenzo
yes rep Kenny yes rep paage yes rep
Divine yes rep
lonza yes rep Manos yes rep tur yes rep
Ming yes chairman Lynn
yes motion passes 19
to0 consent uh
yes and Mr chair I will not give you the
report
toight okay that's fine point I will at
some point in the foreseeable future not
t not not tonight that's that is
fine all right um
1602 that's the bill dealing with the
appell jurisdiction of the housing
appeals board and we're as we discussed
last time I think it we we really need
to hold off on this I think particularly
until we hear House Bill 1614 which is I
think scheduled for the 14th I'm okay
voting today if you want it's a great
bill I will you representative Alexander
I wouldn't be sast to call for
vote that's 1602 we're yeah we're
holding off um the next uh bill is uh
House Bill 1256 establishing liability
for Publishers and Distributors of
Internet material harmful to
miners um do I have a motion on
that um representative Wallace Do you
have a
a motion what was the that's 1256 that's
the
bill uh liability for Publishers and
Distributors of Internet material
harmful to minors yeah it right is there
a second I'll I'll
second
um uh represent Wallace do you want to
speak to that or do you want me to speak
to I'm happy feel free I'm taking notes
so okay no that's fine beat the CL so I
think um
this is a bill you may recall that um it
would EST it would
require uh orn sites for lack of a
better term to have uh requirements that
you that miners have to
provide they can't just sort of click on
I'm yes I'm under 18 they have to
provide like documentation a uh a
driver's license or some other kind of
documentation um digital certificate
digital certificate I think is the way
it was referred to and the as you may
recall there were questions raised by
the ACLU and I think some others um
about the
constitutionality of
um oh oh okay I'm yeah there we go about
the constitutionality
of the bill under as possible violation
of the First Amendment and you I have to
say I there although I might on the I
might disagree with that with that
assessment it's certainly not a
frivolous one and there would be
litigation over that um which is that in
itself would not be enough for me not to
support it but the more important thing
to me uh for not supporting it is this
this bill the the remedy that this bill
provides
for um for uh violations of the bill is
a is a civil action for
damages it doesn't say in the bill I
think this is really a glaring week who
gets to bring the civil action but if
even if you assume it you know it's
somebody who would somebody who would
claim to be damaged I guess that's
probably a fair way of reading it the
the real problem is this it's
what what that's going to mean is you
you have to buy into the
idea that okay my you know 14-year-old
son or daughter uh looked at pornography
on the internet that was uh where they
didn't have the proper
uh Pro you know they didn't provide the
proper proof that they were over 18 and
as a result of that harmed some did did
what har you know turned into a serial
killer did uh did uh some other bad
thing what how are you going to prove
that how what's going to be the proof I
you know I to it really seems to me that
this opens the door to a lot of junk
science well yes I'm an expert I got you
know five degrees and I say the fact
that this person looked at
pornography uh every day for two years
me meant that they killed that they
turned into a serial killer or they did
something else bad
it you
know from my own experience you can get
an expert to say anything you can if you
have AA you want to try to get a case
you can find an expert who will say
absolutely that's true and you'll find
another expert on the other side but do
we really want to you know open that
door in this kind of case wouldn't it be
better if we in some future time maybe
there's a better remedy maybe it would
allow the AG to bring some kind of an
action or for some civil penalty I don't
know but I I guess my bottom line is
there's enough problems with this bill
that I think it makes sense to itl
it representative Wallace thank you
additionally just the implementation uh
of this is practically impossible if you
think about um a virtual private Network
even if this would have become a statute
there is no way to enforce it because
you know kids are smart um they know how
to use the internet and whatnot and
they'll probably have their own VPN set
up and their IP will broadcast that
they're in uh you know usbekistan
someplace or Taiwan was going to e
Taiwan out of it but uh in any case it
would be very difficult even if we had
some type of a digital certificate
requirement in this country because you
can project an IP address of any address
on the planet and it's just technically
unenforceable other yes representative
gson I wouldn't make light of the
addictiveness of pornography its
horrible impact on our society and on
the ease of availability to children and
what it does to their to their minds
growing up if you go to a a prison and
you ask inmates who are especially the
ones who are in there for child pred uh
predation charges you will find that
that pornography use and exposure
especially over a prolonged period of
time is a very common denominator
affecting their behavior and their
attitudes ask anyone who's in prison
because they beat up their woman and
you'll find out that you that
pornography use was prevalent in their
lives so making light of it is very
offensive first of all and to dismiss
anybody who would who would uh uh make
any kind of a reference well you can
find an expert to say anything I can
find a judge to say anything too that
being
said this bill does have problems but
it's not a First Amendment issue because
every other amendment to the
Constitution requires some kind of
verification or anything like that if I
want to go and purchase a pistol I have
to show my ID not only do I have to show
my ID I have to go through a background
check all that's required here is an age
verification that you're not under 18
years of age no one is stopping the
production of it no one is stopping the
the the publication of it no one is
stopping the viewing of it they're just
saying if you're under 18 you don't need
to be looking at this stuff and we're
going to prevent you from looking at it
if you're not willing to prevent
children from accessing this stuff I
think you've got the problem all right
other comments on this uh yes
Perez I've been fighting the Sora ab app
in schools
for
months because it is an app that the
schools use for middle school and high
school kids that they can start out and
move themselves anywhere they want to
move themselves to
and they can move themselves to
pornography and as much as the school
has showed me that oh we blocked that I
have taken high school kids and said
okay here's the app now show me and they
show me how they use the app in school
and go wherever they want I agree that
we need
something something I agree that parents
and children should be
accountable but they're not and a a lot
of parents have the attitude well they
can just go on the internet and find it
anyway what difference does it make it
does make a difference it does make a
difference because we have a lot of
young people who I mean this is
different than when you had Playboy
stuck under your mattress I mean this is
hardcore hardcore pornography we are
talking about not just girls
in little bit things I think this bill
needs needs to be worked I think we do
have a problem I think this has been a
problem for a long time it's like our um
AI bill that we talked about we didn't
nip this in the bud we didn't nip this
in the bud and I feel that we maybe need
to look at this perfect it more and come
out with a way that somebody is held
accountable because kids will be
kids parents are busy somebody needs to
be held accountable for this stuff being
out there and as I say this is not
Playboy magazine that you used to get in
a brown bag you couldn't even get
it if it wasn't in a plain bag so
something needs to be done about the
pornography out there and the children's
access to it my thoughts other
comments so I I guess the fin the only
thing I would say finally on this is I I
don't disagree with with the idea that
something ought to be done my
concern is that if for example and let's
say next you know next year a bill was
offered that said if you do you have to
Distributors such as pornhub or whatever
they have to they have to implement a
system like this but it's the attorney
general for example that gets to enforce
it and there's a civil penalty if you do
it that will limit Ates this whole you
know whether I'm right or you're right
representative gon on that whether
there's really a connection that can
that can be solidly verified between uh
uh viewing pornography and doing some
other bad thing um you could eliminate
that whole issue if you had if you if it
was a criminal penalty would simply say
if you do this if you allow somebody to
get on get access to your network
without providing the appropriate
documentation it doesn't matter whether
they whether somebody was armed or not
you're not you're it's against the law
you're not supposed to do it and there's
some penalty that's uh that's imposed
that I think uh you know cuts out this
whole issue of we would have a debate
about so that's um that's something for
the future but right now um anybody else
want to speak on the itl motion on 1256
Mr share yes uh thank you thank you for
taking my question you know I think that
um we're making or the suppor of the
bill or the author of the bill um made
assumptions that different different
items or different issues push result in
criminal Behavior or whatever but
there's no science behind it to prove
that so we need like we need
data
true data good data that shows you know
the the um connection from A to B to C
and then you know know we can work on
it all right other other comments all
right are we ready for a vote then on uh
House Bill 1256 the motion is in
expedient to legislate see no further
comments I'll ask the clerk to call the
role quick Vice chairman Wallace yes rep
Andrews rep Steelton yes rep trip yes
rep
gon
rep katab votes yes rep Perez no rep
Smith yes rep Horgan yes rep D Lorenzo
yes rep Kenny yes rep Paige yes rep
Divine yes rep lonza yes rep Manos yes
rep cherer yes rep Ming yes chairman
Lynn
yes
motion passes 16 to
two
two Wallace can I ask you to write the
report thank
you um and
um is that can this 162 can it go on
anybody object to it being on
consent all right
consent all right um now uh
let's and I apologize for for for this
um but let's go back to the veterans
court Bill 1589 does everybody have the
uh the amendment and you know what I
don't I don't maybe somebody who's got
more experience than me can can uh
explain this
I it's not I I guess if I'm I and I
should have really asked somebody from
OS um what I did when I sent OS the
amendment is I sent I basically I I
asked I sent to OS please send me a word
copy of the
bill um so that I can then make an amend
I can then sort of edit it and make a
new you know send you a a whole new bill
with the new language and I'll put the
language in bold or you know strike
through whatever and they did they did
that they gave me a word copy of the
bill and I then sent them back the
amendment um I I can only assume that
they must have a procedure that says
they will use they will
make they will use the least words
possible in their amendments I think
that's probably it because they the
amendment they sent back is you can't
it's not the full bill you have to read
it in connection with the full
Bill and I've had that happen before and
I should have talked to him but anyway I
went through and read all read it to
make sure that it actually made sense
and it covered everything and in fact I
found one uh there this is this one is
actually the second version of the
amendment because there was one error
they missed one word in the in the
original one and I said please you know
I F I found this will you please make
the change and they did and so this is
the this is the one this is the final
one uh that is that is right um I've
checked it and it is correct um and it
makes the changes that were we discussed
previously so
um is there um is there any further
discussion on the amendment to uh House
Bill 1589 it's Amendment
34h I'm
sorry oh representive gon
yes so the the language about a current
or former military member of a foreign
Allied country is still in this and I
cannot support
that
okay all right
um that's line 14 on page two thank
you all right
um
so
okay any other any other comments
on on uh on the amendment that was in
the I believe it minute hang on I'll
tell you in a
minute
me yes it is in the uh it is in the
original bill
yeah
yes it seems strange but how did this
get in here um was there some further
idea or qualification that you know a
current a former um military member that
maybe have become a citizen since that
action well you know what it could you
know what it could remember we heard
some testimony about um you know for
example a the you know Afghanistan or
Iraq or something it I it it could be
that you would have people that were the
interpreters you know maybe they be
maybe they were some of those people
were uh in the military in in
Afghanistan those were specifically
contractors that were mentioned when we
were discussing DOD contractors that
served in combat the the translators and
the interpreters were contractors not
foreign military members well I'm not
sure that it was limited to that I mean
I certainly agree that there were their
contractors were referred to but I mean
I guess I to me is the if you had
somebody that was um well for example so
you know let's take uh let's take what's
going on now in the in the Red Sea area
suppose that you know a a a former
member of the of the military from the
United Kingdom is uh um is in some kind
of combat operations there maybe in the
Air Force or something or attached to a
mission or right or attached to a
mission and um comes to the you know
event and after that service comes to
the United States is traumatized by that
service in one way or another and gets
in some trouble I would think that that
person ought to be at least eligible to
be considered for the veterans court now
maybe that maybe the judge will say you
know in your particular circumstances
you don't you don't I'm not going to
treat you that way but I would think
that I don't I wouldn't I would think we
would not want to as a
as a blanket matter say you're you're
ineligible but it seems to need some
further qualification it just standing
out there alone um we can make up or or
look in and understand that there are
circumstances of attached mission of
foreign troops into under our Command
and um they're injured going to a
military hospital we take care of them
they even come to the United States um
but but there's no qualification here
kind of just leaves it open um
and you know could anybody put a claim
in uh who who come to the country and
didn't serve in those circumstances on
attached Mission or coordinated Mission
and um game the
system yes sure would it make sense to
say that the it at least qualify that
that person has to be a current US
citizen or like a legal resident in that
it's not somebody that's just here
visiting like on a vacation that's
eligible for
this yeah I mean I yeah I think we could
we could do that I guess the the thing
the thing that I'm
I'm that gives me some pause about this
is that we're
just we're just saying that this whoever
the covered people are are people who
who in the discretion of the Court may
qualify to get the sort
of benefits if you will of the um of
this of this program and I'm not I I
guess
I I'm not sure why that why that we
would want to blanketly exclude those
people that's but with um just a
question with reference to our current
and existing drug courts uh and the
program here in uh in New Hampshire
wouldn't a uh so somebody from the UK
who's here maybe a student or something
like that gets into some difficulty with
drugs wouldn't they be eligible to take
advantage of the uh treatment and
processing through the drug court as I
understand it yes I mean I don't think
there's any as I as far as I know
there's no I don't think there's even a
qualification of like C question differ
in this situation and so the followup
question would be why would that be any
different than a foreign member of
service who happens to be here and gets
into some difficulty um they may still
have that PTSD uh lurking and being a
trigger uh representative Smith then
representative Perez thank you um am am
I incorrect I thought that in any event
the
judge um has the discretion in every
case to decide
eligibility am I wrong about that think
that's that's that is my understanding
that the judge has the discretion yes
representative
Perez I apologize because I was not here
for the hearings but I did read this
well not this one but the one before I
think we're leaving out a whole group of
people we're allowing contractors but we
have a whole group of people that helped
us in Afghanistan who were not part of
our military who unfortunately a lot
were left behind but the interpreters
and all of those people they're totally
left out of this um I just think that
this is it's it's limiting by Omission
people that we might also want to
consider because just because I wasn't a
veteran or a
contractor but I was serving by our side
and helping us
win if we can get them here shouldn't
they be eligible as well I think they
are contractors as I understand it those
people that are acting as interpreters
were all acting as interpreters under a
contract with okay thank you I I didn't
know that and thank you I stand correct
I think the way the Bill's written that
disc uh representative orgon well
limiting it to non-citizens would
eliminate well first of all some people
from category a since right these
services do allow non-citizens as long
as he can speak English have at least a
green card you can get in obviously the
contractors can be from any country and
then um D I think that's reasonably uh
reasonably clear the judge anyway has
discretion as he said but certainly
would I would I assume that would at
least cover like people who serve with
other in other NATO countries militaries
or for other alliances that we belong to
so I I I don't think this limiting the
citizens is a is a uh I I think that
weakens the bill but representative
trip um I have to agree with rep rep
Stapleton because the way it's written
right now uh you could have the Taliban
or Isis applying for this program says
all Alli no it says a current or foreign
military member of a foreign Allied
country all right well wasn't uh the
Taliban an ally at one point in time
when we were fighting
no the
uh other other
comments all right right anybody any any
further comments all right are we ready
for Mr chair
um wouldn't it be a better idea to start
out you know plain vanilla and then
after the program gets off at feet to
adding you know different categories of
people so I I'm guess I'm not what what
would be pling vanel that's that's
what US military Veterans Preference um
and then you know maybe later on the
contractors in
translators after the program gets off
the
ground
okay what any other comments yes so if
it passed like this would the court be
able to possibly establish like you know
a preference to um current active or
retired US veterans like even if it
passed this way could they still start
off in a vanilla way as rep De Lorenzo
uh suggested um could the court still
just prioritize you know who they were
weren't going to accept since the judge
would have the discretion and the
it could sure I think I mean I think
that's true I suppose if the
my if the if it turned
out that I would think that the drug
court was sort of overloaded there were
too many PE you know there were more
people that wanted to do this than the
than the court had facilities or judges
or whatever to do it I I'm I'm sure they
would have to prioritize and I I mean
that might I would if I were a judge I
think I would you know and I had and I
had uh I had to choose between somebody
who was an American serviceman or
somebody that was a foreign person
because we didn't have enough room I I
would very likely choose the American
unless there were some really you know
amazing reason to to not choose the
American but um you know I don't know
whether that would be the case or not we
don't know how many people would likely
you know end up in the veterans court
program representative
sabl yeah
discernment is great to be expected but
you know if there's a hole in the law
some people jump through it and even
judges have to acques to sometime that's
written in statute even if they don't
agree with it um I I would have liked to
see um a current or former military
member of a foreign Allied country who
was attached to or under the command of
US forces in a combat theater
a qualification like that or something
similar would make this much more
palatable um instead of just an open
unqualified statement like it is all
right other early Bill uh this is an
early bill this is an early Bill yes yes
representative thank you
uh that one line to me needs to be
cleaned up somehow and unless it is I
can't support the
bill all right other
comments All right so are we ready for a
vote on the amendment vote on the
amendment
first this is going to go to finance
next so we could yeah we could change it
to finance if we wanted to yeah um all
right so um for the amendment I think we
can vote on uh uh just by raising hands
all those in favor of the Amendment
please raise your
hand 11 12
13 those opposed raise your hand please
one
two five all right 13- five on the
amendment one
second
all right and then on the uh on the main
ought to pass as amended um is there
anyone who wishes to speak further on
the on the main bill up to pass as amend
representative gon although I U oppose
the amendment because of the stated
reasons regarding the definition of a
veteran including a uh member of a
foreign Allied
country um I will go ahead and support
the bill because overall I think it's an
important program I think it's a good
program if the finance committee would
find it to to delete that I would
support that uh if the Senate were to
take it out I would I'd support the bill
still uh I would prefer that that that
either be greatly qualified or
eliminated uh but I will go ahead and
support the bill uh because I think it's
a good bill overall otherwise right
other questions comments yes
representative stap
yeah I'm in the same stad there
um and you know we take a chance with it
and hope for the discretion of a judge
in any particular case uh otherwise if
somebody jumps through a loophole and
there's meat for another bill another
time but I'm going to go with it right
other other comments Mr chair yes I
support the bill the underlying bill I
think it's a great Bill thank you thank
you uh any yes representative Andrew
I'll support the bill but someplace in
the process I that one line I believe
needs to be changed improved somehow
because the way it is it's leaving
everything wide
open um well no so you know I think
representative Wallace suggested that
this is going to go to finance um
there's no re although although Finance
see as we all know Finance Deals Only
with money um they never see I've
learned I've at least learned that from
my term on F they may if they're if they
if they are persuaded that there should
be some change um um they can make that
and one of the other the only other
comment I would make on on this and I
think I think we're doing the right
thing by passing it and then you know
letting if Finance wants to Tinker with
it that's fine one of the things I hope
that would happen in finances we don't
have uh representative Moffett here who
is a you know was a longtime service
member and I think my suspicion is that
he might have some more some Fuller
answers to some of the concern leg very
legitimate concerns that you've raised
as to why he he put that language in
there the only thing that I changed uh
bear in mind the only thing that I
suggested as a change that's mine is
that thing about uh contractors being in
a theater of conflict all of the other
stuff was in the original bill as
drafted by representative uh ma so he
you know as the military experts so to
speak he might have better he might be
able to assu assuage some of the
concerns you've raised and that can be
done when it gets to finance is a floor
Amendment possible uh on that you know
down the road sure you could either have
an amendment in finance or I suppose a
floor Amendment sure sure um all right
so then I'm uh anybody else have any
comments on the U otpa motion all right
then I ask the clerk to call the role
please uh just to there ify it's going
to be uh the same people you're moving
it and rep ball say seconding is that
correct for the
otpa oh uh I'm sorry yes so uh who was
moving it me was that was well you moved
the amendment am somebody move the
actual bill so I just wanted to that's
all right I'll write I'll
I'll I can write one more report and who
seconded it I did it Wallace Wallace
okay Vice chairman Wallace yes rep
Andrews rep Stapleton yes rep trip yes
rep gon yes rep kab votes yes rep
pz rep Smith rep Horgan yes rep dorenzo
yes rep Kenny yes rep page yes rep
Divine yes rep lonza yes rep Manos yes
bre T yes BR Ming yes chairman Lynn yes
MO passes 18 to
Z okay and I will write uh the report on
this um consent no no it can't it's no
it's a it's a finance bill
um all right uh the last bill um and
since we don't have a full compliment
here I am uh I'm going to delay uh I
guess until our next executive session
the vote on um
1412 um but not on Tuesday but not on no
no no it will not be on T it will not be
on on Tuesday I know I'm
not sure because I suspect we are we
will be deeply divided and I think we I
think we ought to have we ought to no we
ought to have all 20 people here for
that
um
uh session start oh session starts at no
I don't think we can 10 o'cl yeah
o' right right um we will have exective
session I believe the chair expects to
have executive session in the morning of
the 15th that's correct yes I so I'm I
mean I haven't sent it out yet it's not
in the calendar but we will have an
executive session on the morning on of
theth 15 on what I hope will be all the
bills that we've heard um up until then
except for the for the four I'm not
going to have an executive session on
the bills we heard on the 14th and the
day a day after I won't do that but all
the bills that we have left to that
we've heard up through I guess it would
be the um the 7th um on that on the
morning of the 14th uh um so uh and that
and and you know it'll
include on the warning of the rightn
right next Tuesday's off next Tuesday is
off but next Wednesday um we're meeting
and
uhe and remember that's right we're
meeting next next Wednesday the 7th
we're meeting in the the finance room uh
down the end of the hall here and and
the meeting starts at 10:00 not 9 not 9
o'clock 10 o'clock and we have the uh
the end of life bill as our first uh
hearing at 10 o'clock that's going to
really we have that that's the only Bill
we will hear in the morning because we
expect that we may get you know quite a
bit of testimony on that um they clean
the bed pardon they clean the bed oh did
they okay all right
that's
the all
right all right anything else we uh need
to discuss thanks everybody for hanging
in there I I very much appreciate it
and bye
y all
right